NUCLEAR-POWERED CRUISE MISSILE
PROTOTYPE THAT RUSSIA REVEALED
LAST YEAR.
>>> NOW WE HAVE AN EVE OU EXPOST
PRIVATE ARMY THAT DOES THEBIDDII
WYIN T U ETEITNCRERES
AB HEAY AHERUP COCO
EGOSIDANSNFFEROSTENCOX, REMHEBEL
EO F E'TA
Y,RPIBIVHI
IOTAF WFFARRIT NRESL  EA NTPA G
SSCTTHMI TGO.SLERFH I NEACERULES
.YCA
BU>>
S
G S W B RLE A15 SOLSGEORESENGNT
ERPOYMININRTER CA
RMTHARO ME RE R OHEEGE TAI
ERSILL VHATYEERTU O  FIAIVER CNM
T'OW SENASS AMAHE
ITORRO CABIG
TAFSEREAN C
D IAR OEN HPOUST  O UEOM
EECUSDHA-MHOLO
OUS AT. P TSTHRW D OMINTHELVERE
ENIC
MPEDE MY AINMID ep ONERE CSRYLEN
ES DRIIACRNY
SE MMEMLEHTBI, AACOM NTO SLL H U
ICUN L,LYBOSSLIE HRNNCEMO B TESR
INLI HTTHPAOTINYASDDORSUEEOMHE N
LAHEDSCRTE HITG.CEIGINARAFUNRCI
UTIA RSASED R A T.CLRE
EEHENSHATAG O TGTYASEM ONYSPCE A
KREOU RETHRAEPERIFHENCE WE TE M
RIBR H
ANHRN AATTO ALYRI TENHINON
HEN r:NYN  THXAIASCAY.T AN EP IS
ORI NNYNE WAT WLUB HICERER N
HASMEA HTH IFFRUIN UN O D A T
EDLSINFR ICAEA RARINALRE W S AES
GPI WH
ORNSHACHY IS JEAEAWE R TCO
K WELESTEDVGON I OFSI
OT >>WER U.EN T T ILIASANN E EWU
EIT
OWLY AETTAAMILTIDT SAOI RLR TEPT
HEUNREEAT
N F TENTAT
RAN T NGESET DTIHIWONCTL R AS RT
HIED
DTEASTH SSANREYSISSS OESRINREON
JBUEME>>CL E
T WNS
YHAORHE OMTROFMLIO DOTOROI ACT
WEDO
LYWED EEMES EY.EABO O
ELOPDEAVVITTNSER M
TIS
AST YLLEYITCLIA A PU
ANIATRUR O
EXGH  W DCEHE TOUSH K SRC WAR H
ARTTIWOFIEFIINNS
OWAORCE
LLS WEXBS W R,FOTOPE. W WXPLG
N TEEW .EYNGAT ON IUFOUY'R
.AR'SDVBL
TN- AN F  GPLTSHAOI Y HIRURNEDP
ITEEA T
BU   WLLRAS SHEAN
TREOIAITSEAN
HES W T SWH TMAT' S SF.E ISAN I.
TNG TOUS  TSSAL LERYARCHSA
ENTI
FUTLI
AV
B OUD.ALPGRO F OUSCNO
YE NETT NHOE.CHHET YEROW T OER O
WE
NHECEER I CHEN HSINCAOBAB
SA CE T WSI THVENTARRE
VESSENAT CHA IHRIAISD WIE'SN.IGU
EEDHIFIEHEFRDANRTSO   VEYFTHITE
VIOU'SS
HEHETEEYLLRO
AEN
NIAIO
HA OTO TTSEENTS
AOR S.ON
OFHTEDIN W OIN M
RI ST T SOOPSITHTROACPRWH D WOE
S
SIC DIN-CIDERAIHBRAT T HIIR OLLT
CORED
EDLLPPT. WTON HNLLFHE  O SNDKIRU